a young fella who put the Fonz on hold
while he made two hit movies last year
and he did it the hard way without any
acting advice for me
with him one of the glittering jewels in
the Hollywood treasure chest greer
garson and henry winkler right here
we just like to say that it is an honor
to stand here tonight with a star of
your magnitude why that's very gracious
of you we could call it a nice encounter
of the Academy kind couldn't wait what
would you say if I told you I was really
delighted to be up here with the forms
I'd say you show good taste
I think the Academy showed good taste
and giving you the award missus benefit
why thank you Henry and now let us name
the talented and gifted people who have
been nominated for their great
achievements in art direction the
nominees are
George C Webb for Airport 77 set
direction by Mickey s Michael
Joell lives and Don dimino for Close
Encounters of the Third Kind set
decoration by filled Abramson
10 Adam and Peter Lomond for Spy Who
Loved Me set their separate set
decoration by you skate
John Larry Norman Reynolds and Leslie
Denis for Star Wars set decoration by
Roger Christian
Albert Brenner for the turning point set
decoration by Marvin March
and the winner is ah John Barry Norman
Reynolds and as negative a store
we're very pleased to accept this
beautiful award on behalf of all our
friends and Patriots have worked so hard
to make the sets of Star Wars a success
and there's one man whose name should be
engraved on this above everybody else
and whose name should be on every frame
of Star Wars and that's George Lucas
thank you George
you